you
I
back to the music
okay just the top thing not the crowd
you
please be seated mr. president seated
before you our trustees faculty alumni
candidates for degrees and honored
guests to the University assembled for
the annual commencement in colombia's
two hundred and forty eighth academic
year with your permission mr. president
the exercises will now begin please
stand for the national anthem
Oh
I
please be seated the opening words will
now be pronounced by Janel Davis the
university chaplain congratulations 2002
graduates you will leave columbia
university today with both
responsibility and privilege your
columbia degree will identify you around
the globe among the best educated women
and men in the world an educated leader
you must be ready to think and do lead
and follow advise and listen your
education is a sacred trust you have
earned the privilege to choose humility
compassion courage integrity and justice
as lifelong touchstones an understanding
of the responsibility and privilege of
educated men and women was set out by w
eb d boys with these words give us grace
to realize that education is not simply
doing the things we like studying the
tasks that appeal to us or wandering in
the world of thought whither and where
we will in a universe where good is
hidden underneath evil and pleasure
lurks in pain we must work if we would
learn and know it is the unpleasant task
the hard lesson the bitter experience
that often leads to knowledge and power
and good graduates may your dreams chart
your journey your visions guide your
days your imagination give you courage
and your hopes keep you safe stay close
to Columbia returned to Columbia often
to challenge your mind to nurture your
imagination and to refresh your soul may
it be so with God's help congratulations
Godspeed
Oh
we
is
Oh
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the University good morning what a
fabulous day and what a wonderful place
to enjoy it in my nine years as
president of Columbia I have never seen
a happier brighter better prepared
assembly than this fabulous class of
2002 in a short while we will honor with
the university medal for excellence and
Columbia degrees honoris causa eight
special classmates their predecessors
span the centuries from Abraham Lincoln
to Winston Churchill Margaret Mead
Desmond Tutu today we add to that
luminous roster as you can see it is a
remarkable gathering of talent among the
honorees is my illustrious successor the
incoming president of Columbia
University Lee Bollinger please join me
in welcoming all of our honorary members
of the class of 2002
you surely can cheer better than that
you'll have
that's a good warm-up because now I ask
you to give a resounding cheer for those
who helped you reach this day your
mentors and teachers and your loving
families and loyal friends
those of you who turned and looked at
the gathered assembly are expressing on
behalf of all of us our recognition of
how crucial it has been that loving
families and loyal friends have provided
the support that has made this set of
accomplishments possible we are here to
recognize the attainments of a group of
students who are at the heart of our
university the women and men who
graduates today from Columbia College
Thank
it's hard not to observe your more
energetic and self-congratulation than
in thanking others but we're also here
to honor the graduating seniors from one
of the finest undergraduate institutions
in the world Barnard College
we are here we are here as well to suit
to salute the multi-talented graduates
of Columbia's eminent fou foundation
school of engineering and applied
science
and we are here we are here to applaud
those who have worked hard and
diligently to earn your degrees from
America's finest liberal arts college
for adults the school of general studies
we raise we raise a special cheer and
here I think we should all cheer not
expect this group of graduates only to
cheer for itself we all cheer for those
who have completed your work at one of
this country's oldest and most
prestigious schools for Advanced Study
in research the Columbia Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences we we celebrate as
well the superbly prepared graduates of
our stellar School of Architecture
planning and preservation we praise the
gift of graduates of our acclaimed
School of the Arts we hail the dedicated
graduates of the oldest accredited
school in its field the Columbia School
of Social Work
today today we congratulate our skilled
and newly minted dentists nurses public
health professionals and physicians and
surgeons
we welcome to the pursuit of justice are
worthy graduates of Columbia's
outstanding school of law
today we affirm our future knowing that
we can entrust our children to the
newest graduates of the nation's best
teachers college
we have confidence that others of you
will make it your mission to give us
accurate reporting graduates of
Colombia's great School of Journalism we
count on a planet made safer and more
prosperous by the worldly men and women
from Arras America's pre-eminent School
of International and public affairs and
we expect the prosperity will go
hand-in-hand with social responsibility
for you who graduate today from Colombia
splendid School of Business
to all of you congratulations on
becoming our newest alumni
this is a time for celebration we sound
the trumpets we unfurl the banners but
even as we shout and cheer and applaud
you and your achievements we know that
your final year will also forever be
marked by the tragedy that has come to
be known simply as 911 the horrific
events of that day are etched into our
memories as vivid scenes of deliberately
inflicted death and destruction and
marked indelibly by the loss of many of
our friends and loved ones in the larger
Columbia family 911 symbolizes some of
the most pressing challenges that
confront our world the world for which
you will be providing leadership as you
know I too will be moving on to new
responsibilities so on this occasion of
our shared commencement I take the
liberty of framing two challenges that
we will all face together challenge that
come challenges that come into sharp
focus when viewed through the lens of
911 the first challenge concerns what is
widely characterized as globalization
most Americans have viewed globalization
both as a way of extending the reach of
Western Commerce and communication and
is a source of inexpensive products and
services there are certainly also
anxieties about a potential loss of jobs
and concerns about threats to
environmental standards but 911 has
focused our attention on how much more
fundamental are the challenges of
globalization entails globalization
means that business and the media can
operate quickly on a worldwide basis it
also means that the hatred and violence
nurtured by envy and ex
inclusion and ideologically Laden
differences anywhere in the world are
very near to us we are all at Ground
Zero our destiny cannot be divorced from
the fate of the rest of the world
including those furthest from us in
geography ideology and socioeconomic
status the United States may be the
world's lone superpower but we cannot
simply impose our will even on those who
seem relatively powerless 911 in effect
forced our leaders to rethink the
pre-emptive unilateralism so evident in
American policy in the months before the
tragedy the abrogation of the Kyoto
Protocol the move toward missile defense
apart from any discussions even with the
lies the refusal for 15 long months to
take an active role in seeking to
resolve the israeli-palestinian conflict
a more positive expression of our sense
of connection to the fate of the rest of
the world occurred in March when more
than 50 heads of state and other leaders
met in Monterrey Mexico to address the
imperative of financing development so
that the benefits of globalization can
be more broadly distributed just before
those meetings president bush announced
that the United States would increase
foreign economic assistance by fifty
percent over three years after a decade
of stagnant development budgets that is
the most welcome step in the right
direction though it will still leave the
US at the bottom of the 25 most
developed countries and the percentage
of the gross domestic product devoted to
foreign assistance to be specific
even after this projected increase the
United States will devote about 15
hundredths of one percent of our gross
domestic product to foreign assistance
out of a hundred dollars out of a
hundred dollars we will give 15 cents
hundred dollars fifteen cents as a
fraction of the total economy that will
be one seventh as much as Denmark
already gives and about one-fifth of
what we officially agreed at the World
Food Summit in 1996 was an appropriate
target for all advanced industrialized
countries so as we applaud the
commitment of the United States to move
closer to doing our fair share we must
also recognize how far we have yet to go
in this regard a report in this
morning's New York Times is encouraging
bono for the benefit of those of us who
are over 30 the lead singer in the band
u2 yes but the other person I'll mention
are ones that people under 30 are less
likely to know our treasury secretary
Paul O'Neill these two are traveling in
Africa to see which development programs
are most effective the delegation may be
an odd couple but its purpose is right
on target the deliberations in monterrey
also addressed trade here too
performance is far less impressive than
our announced intentions Jack Beatty
sums up the situation succinctly in a
recent column in The Atlantic Monthly
its title is do as we say not as we do
the most recent major international
trade agreement the Uruguay Round
concluded in 1994 set out a
straightforward bargain
the developed countries would reduce
their agricultural subsidies and the
developing countries would in return
lower their tariffs on agricultural
imports in Beatty's words the developing
countries met their part of the bargain
by having their average tariffs the
developed countries renamed subsidies
have in recent years made up almost
forty percent of the value of Western
farm output about the same as when
you're gay and Uruguay Round started the
cost of developing countries of this
failure of globalization is enormous for
agriculture alone Western export
subsidies and trade barriers amount to
more than five times the total of
Western foreign aid manufactured goods
from developing from the developing
world also face tariff barriers that are
on average four times as high as those
levied on products from the
industrialized world this state of
affairs is simply hard to defend to
quote the subtitle of Beatty's peace
globalization might actually be good for
poor countries if only rich countries
played by the rules one challenge we
face together is then to make
globalization work for the impoverished
as well as the wealthy
it's a pleasure that the School of
International and public affairs led
that cheer to meet this challenge will
certainly require more generous programs
of foreign assistance than the post Cold
War post-war world has yet produced but
it will also entail designing incentives
and when necessary enforcement
mechanisms to assure that all the
players follow the rules of the game if
meeting this first challenge is to be
more than a wistful hope it leads
directly to the second challenge we face
which also comes into sharp focus when
viewed through the lens of 911 the
relationship between private incentives
and public standards between market
mechanisms and governmental policies the
tragedy of 911 brought a new
appreciation for the legitimate roles of
government as a representation of
community concern care and support in
this city personalized so remarkably by
Mayor Rudy Giuliani as a resource for
emergency services as a locus for
security in a time of extreme anxiety as
an arbiter among competing claims as a
source of funding for compensation and
reconstruction markets are no doubt
crucial for efficient economic
development data from the past two
decades on an increasingly worldwide
basis spare powerful witness to the
dynamism of freer markets but 911
reminds us that markets work best when
there are rules of the game that all the
players
airport security is a telling
illustration of what happens when public
services are contracted out to private
firms without adequate attention to
performance standards profits for the
vendor can be high even if cost of the
purchase there are low as long as there
is little concern for quality control
the solution to this problem is not
simply to make airport personnel
government employees it is instead to
design a system that preserves
incentives for vendors while at the same
time insisting that publicly impose
standards of quality must be met the
same position holds through such complex
services as welfare and job training
private contracts profit motives and
other incentives may well have a
constructive role to play in injecting
efficiency and overcoming complacency
but important though such means may be
the end to be achieved is the public
good and in each case even private
vendors must be held accountable to
publicly monitored standards of quality
in the heyday of unbridled enthusiasm
for the dynamism of markets and for the
unfailing wisdom of the invisible hand
it was hard for advocates of government
responsibility for regulation to get a
hearing in fact in this country at least
it still is and should be tough to
impose regulations we all hate red tape
and bureaucracy as my family and friends
will confirm I probably dislike such
intrusions as much as anyone but just in
case we were beginning to forget the
lesson of 911 we had another teachable
moment this spring the Enron Corporation
through its extensive network of
connections and on the basis of wide and
deep campaign contributions lobby
vigorously and successfully to have many
of its transactions exempted from the
regulations that govern the ended energy
industry this exemption from regulation
is certainly not the cause of Enron's
collapse but the absence of oversight
justice certainly did contribute to a
climate in which the unrestrained
self-interest of senior executives
overwhelmed other considerations
including the interests of other
employees and fellow shareholders so
today we are challenged to rethink and
reorder the ways we live together first
globalization requires a reorientation
of our stance in the international arena
a reorientation that recognizes how
intimately we are interconnected with
even those most distant from us and
second along with our embrace of markets
we must affirm the legitimate role of
public institutions and requiring
adherence to rules of conduct sand
standards of quality to which all
participants are held accountable you
are most recent graduates will
participate in this rethinking and
reordering for the rest of your lives
you will be not only players but also
the theoreticians the policymakers the
executives who helped determine the
rules of the game in the confidence that
columbia has contributed to your
capacity for such leadership I wish each
one of you all the best for all of our
sake thank you and congratulations
the Provost of the University Jonathan
our coal will now present the University
medal for excellence and the candidates
for the degrees in honoris causa mr.
president I have the honor to present
the university medal for excellence to
George Dion kabbalists physician and
scientist
you
my Latins good but not that good Georgie
uncouple asst for the university medal
for excellence son of Columbia gifted
scholar and scientist creative leader in
medicine and business we honor you today
for the powerful relevance of your
scientific accomplishments a brilliant
triple Columbia degree holder with a
bachelor's degree from Columbia College
an MD from the College of Physicians and
Surgeons and a PhD from the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences a Howard
Hughes fellow a Lucille be Marquis
cholera Columbia adjunct professor and
chief scientific officer of Lee a
leading biotechnology company you have
provided new therapeutic methods for
controlling neurological disorders
metabolic diseases and cancer unless
ting enlisting molecular biology in the
conquest of disease you have become the
exemplar of the modern physician
scientist Columbia takes great pride in
awarding to one of our own the
university medal for excellence
mr. president I have the honor to
present Joan Didion novelist and
essayist for the degree Doctor of
Letters honoris causa
Joan Didion for the degree of Doctor of
Letters honoris causa a magical alchemy
of precision elegance and diamond hard
language mark you as a true original
with a spare pneus of style that leaves
the reader room to think and feel you
have brought to English prose for
decades of innovative fiction and
commentary your collections of
nonfiction slouching toward Bethlehem
and the White Album have placed the
personal essay at the center stage in
modern literature melding the personal
and the political with remarkable
dexterity you have given us a body of
work novels essays and screenplays of
power insight and profound influence on
writers of successive generations
Columbia is pleased to award you the
degree of Doctor of Letters honoris
causa
mr. president I have the honor to
present Roberto Gonzalez echeveria for
the degree Doctor of Letters honoris
causa
you
gilberto Gonzalez echevarria for the
degree of Doctor of Letters honoris
causa speaking little Lilly English when
you arrived from Cuba at age 16 you
became a master the language of
Shakespeare as well as those of
cervantes balzac and Dante today you're
influential studies in the voice of the
Masters myth and archive and Celestine
is brewed are widely read and honored on
three continents in your work you have
related literature to the law science
history philosophy anthropology and
baseball at the center of critical
debates in Hispanic you have earned a
permanent place in literary history as
sterling professor of Hispanic and
comparative literature at Yale
University at the pinnacle of your field
you continue to help shape the
discipline of literary criticism and to
inspire future generations of scholars
Columbia is privileged to bestow upon
you the degree of Doctor of Letters
honoris causa
mr. president I have the honor to
present lisi Bollinger president of
Columbia University for the degree
Doctor of Laws honoris causa Lisi
Bollinger for the degree of Doctor of
Laws honoris causa lifelong advocate of
a more tolerant society you returned to
Columbia as president to lead us as we
set the course for this new century you
have redefined academic leadership first
as dean of the university of michigan
law school and then as president of that
university authoring groundbreaking
books that lead us to respect to diverse
views that enrich our national discourse
participating in public debate on urgent
issues and sharing your perspectives as
the teacher of undergraduates having
reasserted the university's role as
guardian and from we promulgate ER of
culture you return to this great city
where art and culture touch us all as an
avid runner and a master medalist in the
New York City millrose games you
understand endurance as well as
leadership Columbia is proud to welcome
you home for what we will hope will be a
long and successful run as our 19th
president with a degree of Doctor of
Laws honoris causa
mr. president I have the honor to
present George J Mitchell statesman and
public servant for the degree Doctor of
Laws honoris causa
George J Mitchell for the degree of
Doctor of Laws honoris causa visionary
public servant and global ambassador for
peace you're an inspiring model for
selfless devotion to the hard work of
democracy a Senate Majority Leader you
steered key initiatives to victory
including basic environmental
legislation and path-breaking child care
law since leaving the Senate you have
confronted the most intransigent
international problems as a peace
negotiator in Northern Ireland pointing
the way to the good friday agreement of
1998 and as chair of the Sharm el-sheikh
fact-finding committee on the
israeli-palestinian conflict bringing a
ray of hope to the gray skies of the
Middle East for your courageous
dedication to a better world Colombia is
honored to confer upon you the degree of
Doctor of Laws honoris causa
mr. president I have the honor to
present Ruth J Simmons president of
Brown University for the degree Doctor
of Laws honoris causa Ruth J Simmons for
the degree of Doctor of Laws honoris
causa as the 12th child of East Texas
sharecroppers now the 18th president of
one of America's oldest and finest
universities you are the inspirational
embodiment of the American dream your
years of leadership at Spelman College
Princeton University and smith college
have been dedicated to the conviction
that education embodies the power to
transform lives and extend life chances
as an innovative leader in opening elite
institutions to the disadvantaged you
bring to your new mission as president
of Brown University welcome insight
boundless energy and passionate
commitment for your extraordinary
leadership in higher education and for
speaking out and fighting for what is
right Columbia salutes you with a degree
of Doctor of Laws honoris causa
mr. president I have the honor to
present Jack thiessen composer and
teacher for the degree Doctor of music
honoris causa
Jack Beason for the degree of Doctor of
Music honoris causa not so quick with
your galaxy of successful operas in
which Lizzie Borden is the central
radiant star you have given thousands of
listeners the world over the pleasures
of music glide with passion and drama
humor and satire your song sonatas and
symphonies have confirmed the best
judges high regard for your inspired
versatility you followed the tradition
of a teacher composer established by
Edward MacDowell when he founded the
columbia music department more than a
century ago for more than three decades
your accomplishments have drawn into
your orbit our most talented students
eager to learn under your painstaking
care the open secrets of your heart of
your art and heart columbia is proud to
cap the many honors you have received by
conferring upon you the degree Doctor of
music honoris causa
mr. president I have the honor to
present Brenda Milner scientific pioneer
for the degree Doctor of Science honoris
causa
Brenda Milner for the degree of Doctor
of Science honoris causa your pioneering
research fueled the knowledge explosion
about the critical relationship between
human memory and the brain nearly a half
century ago you too detailed the amnesia
that was that resulted when the
hippocampus of the brain was surgically
lesion in an effort to alleviate
seizures in documenting the disturbing
results of this surgery you made a
profound contribution to medicine to our
understanding of mental processes and to
consequent decades of intense study of
memory and cognitive functions related
to specific regions of the brain for
your insight into how the brain works
Columbia proudly bestows upon you the
degree of Doctor of Science honoris
causa
the president of the University will now
present the awards for excellence in
teaching
I have the privilege of presenting five
further honors through which we
recognized faculty colleagues for their
outstanding contributions as teachers
nominations were solicited and received
from students fellow faculty and alumni
a faculty committee made the final
selection I ask that each awardee stand
as I call your name so that we may
acknowledge this great contribution to
our common life as an educational
institution unfortunately our first
awardee could not be with us but our
admiration for her is such that we must
honor her even in absentia Cathy Eden
known for your daunting erudition in
your capacity to wield it with lucidity
precision and grace you have a deep love
for the study of literature matched by a
strong commitment to teaching it to
others and a deep wisdom about how that
can best be done sig VAR g gisler
your commitment to the do you want to
hear what we have to say about him your
commitment to the mission and crafted
rigorous journalism is surpassed only by
your capacity to inspire your students
to dig deeper to write better and behave
more ethically in the process
congratulations Thomas J cats your
introduction of generations of
undergraduates to the excitement of
chemistry and your extraordinary
mentoring of doctoral candidates have
launched more distinguished careers and
changed more lives than we can count
congratulations Archie Rand you have a
boundless ability to inspire in your
students a love of all visual language
and also the capacity to signal that it
is appropriate to pursue knowledge as
the valued companion of artistic
practice
Gerald E Thompson your Distinguished
Service is the teaching physician and a
mentor has made you an unparalleled
model for an entire generations of
physician in the making and by own
example as a bedside teacher you have
shown them how to think and care I
congratulate all five of you we are
honored that you are with us and we
applaud your good work the Provost of
the University will now present the
administrative officers of the various
divisions of the University who will in
turn introduced candidates for the
degrees in course in their respective
groups those candidates will be expected
to rise as they are being introduced
until the conferring that the degrees is
completed mr. president it's my pleasure
to introduce Austin equally Dean of
Columbia College
mr. president before you stands the
columbia college class of 2002 the
extraordinary talented candidates of the
faculty of Columbia's original college
of 1754 who after years of unflagging
effort and unceasing valor have
completed the daunting and almost
impossible requirements prescribed by
that faculty for the degree of Bachelor
of Arts I request you sir to grant these
amazing young people this degree along
with the rights privileges and
responsibilities thereby entailed
next mr. president I have the pleasure
of introducing three galil
dean of the faculty of the fou
foundation school of engineering and
applied science
mr. president before you stand the
candidates of the faculty of the full
Foundation School of Engineering and
Applied Science they possess electrical
personality environmental awareness
biomedical excellence and great
chemistry and they have been blessed
with computer confidence mechanical
aptitude industrial strength applied
ingenuity and civil responsibility these
candidates have completed the
requirements prescribed by the Faculty
for the degrees of Bachelor of Science
Master of Science professional and
engineering degree and doctor of
engineering science I ask you please say
to grant them these degrees along with
the rights and privileges thereto
attached
I am pleased mr. president to introduce
Judith our Shapiro president of Barnard
College
residental up you've worked so hard for
this degree you want to hear yourselves
get it president rupp you are no doubt
aware that before you stand the audibly
splendid and splendidly audible members
of the Bar nerd class of 2002 they have
completed the requirements prescribed by
the bar nerd faculty for the degree of
Bachelor of Arts and I know that they
will remember your years at this
university as fondly as they remember
their own if you grant them this degree
together with all the rights privileges
and responsibilities thereto pertaining
it's my pleasure mr. president to
introduce Peter J on dean of the faculty
of general studies
mr. president before you stand the
imaginative innovative and deeply
indebted candidates of the faculty of a
unique college in the Ivy League
Columbia School of general studies they
have completed the requirements
prescribed by that faculty for the
degrees of Bachelor of Arts and Bachelor
of Science I entreat you sir to grantham
these degrees along with the rights and
privileges thereto attached next mr.
president it's my pleasure to introduce
Bruce W Ferguson being of the Faculty of
the arts
mr. president to your far far left
appropriately enough stand the
candidates of the Faculty of the School
of the Arts professional artists of all
media and of enormous distinction who
will delight enliven amuse confound and
finally elevate us in the near future
and who have thankfully completed the
requirements prescribed by that faculty
for the degree of Master of Fine Arts I
beg and beseech you sir indeed I plead
with you to grant these degrees along
with the rights and privileges thereto
attached I am pleased mr. president to
introduce Lisa Anderson Dean of the
Faculty of International and public
affairs
mr. president welcome to the CEPA Alumni
Association before you stand the
candidates of the faculty of
International and public affairs these
remarkable individuals knew well before
September 11th how important
globalization and public service would
be to all of us they are dedicating
their lives to making their community
and their world more just more secure
more prosperous and more peaceful they
have completed the requirements
prescribed by the Faculty for the
degrees of Master of Public
Administration and master of
International Affairs please sir grant
them these degrees along with the rights
and responsibilities thereto attached
mr. president's now my pleasure to
introduce Sheila be camerman interim
dean of the faculty of Social Work
mr. president before you stand also to
your left the compassionate and
idealistic candidates of the Faculty of
Social Work who have completed who have
completed the requirements prescribed by
that faculty for the degrees of Master
of Science and doctoral Social Welfare I
beg you sir the great to them these
degrees along with the rights and
privileges thereto attached now mr.
president it's my pleasure to introduce
IRB Lamster dean of the faculty of
dental and oral surgery
mr. president before you stand the
candidates of the faculty of dental and
oral surgery class of 2002 who have
completed the requirements prescribed by
that faculty for the degrees of Master
of Science and Doctor of Dental Surgery
this is my first class they are an
outstanding group of individuals who
will be a continued source of pride for
their alma mater I beg you sir to grant
them these degrees along with the rights
and privileges thereto attached and next
mr. president it's my pleasure to
introduce mayor feldburg the end of the
faculty of business
mr. president
before you stand the quintessential
candidates of the Faculty of the
Graduate School of Business we will
completed the requirements prescribed by
that faculty for the degree of Master of
Business Administration I request you
sir to grant him this degree along with
the rights and privileges thereto
attached thank you it's my pleasure mr.
president to introduce Thomas J
goldstein Dean of the Faculty of
journalism mr. president standing before
you are the rambunctious spot wise the
hard-charging but courteous the sweet
tempered but tough minded the concise
yet eloquent the fearless and very
independent seekers of truth and justice
candidates of the faculty of journalism
they have completed the requirements
prescribed by our faculty for the degree
of Master of Science I ask you
respectfully sir to grant them this
degree along with the rights and
privileges thereto attached
now mr. president I'm pleased to
introduce author levine president of
Teachers College
mr. president behind you to the side of
you at the forefront of this assembly
then the candidates the Faculty of
Teachers College whose quiet dignity and
innate modesty would be offended were I
to use a string of overblown adjectives
to describe the superlative qualities
suffice it to say these extraordinarily
able and idealistic graduates are the
best of their generation and committed
to achieving social justice nor time
they have completed the requirements of
our faculty four degrees of Master of
Arts Master of Education Master of
Science and doctor of Education
I beseech you to grant them these
degrees with the Associated
responsibilities and rights because they
have important work to do
I am pleased mr. president to introduce
bernard tschumi dean of the faculty of
architecture planning and preservation
mr. president before you stand the
experimental and yet highly constructive
the inquisitive and soon to be highly
influential candidates of the faculty of
architecture planning and preservation
we have completed the requirements
prescribed by that faculty for the
degrees of Master of Architecture Master
of Science I beg you sir to grant this
extraordinary class these degrees along
with the rights and responsibilities
thereto attached next mr. president it's
my pleasure to introduce David W LeBron
Dean of the Faculty of Law
mr. president who for you stand the
brilliant diverse socially committed and
enthusiastic prescribed by our faculty
for the degrees of juris doctor Master
of Laws and Doctor of the science of law
I ask you sir to grant them these
degrees along with the rights and
privileges attached thereto so that they
may go forth and contribute in myriad
ways to justice and to our best
aspirations for our world and indeed
protect all the rights and privileges
you are conferring on Columbia students
today mr. president it is now my
pleasure to introduce gerald d fischbach
executive vice president for health and
biomedical sciences and Dean of the
Faculty of Medicine College of
Physicians and Surgeons who will
administer the Hippocratic oath
mr. president I'm proud to present to
you candidates for the degrees from the
Faculty of Medicine they are a brilliant
creative caring and energetic group who
yesterday made the innovative suggestion
that we suspend admissions to the
medical school because it is unlikely
that we will ever recruit a better group
they have completed the requirements
prescribed by the Faculty of Medicine
for the degrees of masters of science
and clinical microbiology master of
science and human nutrition Master of
Science and occupational therapy Master
of Science and physical therapy and
doctor of medicine their experience has
been enriched by this great being part
of this great University and mr.
president by your leadership during
their tenure and we respectfully request
that you grant these individuals the
degrees along with the rights and
privileges thereto attached mr.
President may we also request your
permission to administer the oath of
Hippocrates to the candidates for the
doctor of medicine this custom was
established more than 2,000 years ago
that no one may be admitted to our
profession without first expressly
undertaking its obligations most
relevant today now therefore we call
upon you to take as we have taken before
you the oath that bears the name of
Hippocrates the language in which our
predecessors first took the oath is no
longer spoken the very gods they call to
witness are no longer relevant but still
we can find no more noble words than the
most ancient in which to hand down the
traditions of our calling you do
solemnly swear by whatever each of you
holds most
that you will be loyal to the profession
of medicine and just and generous to its
members that you will lead lives and
practice your art in uprightness and
honor that into whatsoever house you
shall enter it shall be for the good of
the sick to the utmost of your power
holding yourselves far aloof from wrong
from corruption from the tempting of
others to vice that you will exercise
your art solely for the cure of your
patients and will give no drug perform
no operation for a criminal person
purpose even if solicited far less
suggested that whatsoever you shall see
or hear of the lives of your patients
which is not fitting to be spoken you
will keep inviolable secret these things
do you swear let each of you bow your
head and a sign of acquiescence and now
if you will be true to this your oath
may good repute ever be yours if the
opposite if you shall prove yourselves
for Warren
and now mr. president I'm pleased to
introduce Mary o Mun dinger Dean of the
School of Nursing
mr. president before you stand the
accomplished candidates of the
distinguished faculty of Nursing who
have completed the requirements
prescribed by that faculty for the
degrees of Bachelor of Science Master of
Science and Doctor of Nursing science
they are among the nation's most
precious resources I ask you sir to
grant them these degrees along with the
rights and privileges thereto attached
next mr. president I'm pleased to
introduce Alan g rosenfield Dean of the
mailman School of Public Health
mr. president thank you for getting my
diplomas before you stand the prevention
oriented socially committed diverse and
brilliant class of two thousand to the
candidates of the faculty of the mailman
School of Public Health who are
dedicated to help this nation fix our
difficult and flawed system of health
care they have completed the
requirements prescribed by the Faculty
for the Master of Public Health Master
of Science and doctor of Public Health I
request you sir that you grant to them
these degrees along with the rights and
privileges here too attached and last
mr. president it is my pleasure to
introduce Henry C pinkham Dean of the
Faculty of the Graduate School of Arts
and Sciences
mr. president before you stand the
candidates of the Faculty of the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences who
have completed the requirements
prescribed by that faculty for the
degrees of Master of Arts Master
philosophy Doctor of Philosophy and
Doctor of Musical Arts I beg you sir to
grant to them these degrees along with
the rights and privileges thereto
attached will all candidates for degrees
in course please rise for the conferring
of degrees by the president
the appropriate academic authorities
have determined and if so reported to me
those students who have satisfactorily
completed the course of study prescribed
by the Faculty under which they have
been enrolled as a candidate for a
university degree in accordance with the
authority vested in me as president of
the University I now admit each of you
to the degree for which you have
qualified in token whereof you will
subsequently receive your diploma
congratulations
the audience is requested to please rise
and join in the singing of Stan Colombia
and to remain standing until after the
benediction is pronounced by Rabbi
Menachem Meyer
you
mr. president honored guests
distinguished graduates including many
of my former students and my dear
elisheva you the graduates you the
graduates should know a fundamental
eternal truth your parents love you
deeply I am in a year of mourning for my
beloved mother who died about six months
ago the United States is also in a year
of mourning after the most heinous
attack on American soil killing over
3,000 innocent people my thoughts today
reflect the values of my mother of
blessed memory and her attitude towards
the United States a refugee from Nazi
Germany she arrived on these shores in
the 1930s without a formal education but
with great wisdom the majesty of America
mesmerised her throughout her long life
she saw America as a land of
unparalleled opportunity with education
the key to growth she would frequently
say get the best education you can
nobody can ever take that away from you
you the graduates of Columbia University
are certainly the beneficiaries of the
finest education there is yet another
fundamental fundamental lesson to be
learned outside of the lecture hall the
profits a career and joined those
responsible for governing a nation to
establish authentic justice and deal
compassionately with people these twin
values of justice and compassion
represent the legacy of the prophetic
tradition both values are rooted in the
conviction that every human being is
created in the image of God together
these values form the eternal Twin
Towers of the American structure our
Declaration of Independence sets out
among our inalienable rights life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
it provides a broad foundation for a
just society some 100 years later the
poet Emma Lazarus gave equally profound
expression to America's sense of
compassion with her immortal words give
me your tired your poor your huddled
masses yearning to breathe free our
American society based on the twin
values of justice and compassion is
precisely what the attacks of September
11th sought to destroy but those events
succeeded only in strengthening us never
in our history has there been such an
overwhelming expression of justice and
compassion may these eternal Twin Towers
of the American structure energize us
and serve as our compass as we walk the
road of life with its complexities and
challenges maybe may the Almighty Plus
each and every one of you and may God
bless america
until the academic procession has passed
guests at the University and the
graduates are requested to please remain
in their places that concludes
you